holy [ __ ] remember we all thought
Jurassic Park was dead Jurassic Park 3
couldn't kill your childhood franchise
nothing can Jurassic world
so Jurassic world is a new Jurassic
movie in the Jurassic Park franchise
it's not a reboot I mean the events of
the old Jurassic Park actually happened
which this movie never actually explains
how after that catastrophe they opened
this park like illegally speaking it's
like yeah we can totally open this park
and people will come and visit further
proof people are idiots I guess so in
Jurassic world Bryce Dallas Howard is
more or less the overseer of the park
and they're doing some crazy stuff like
you saw on the trailer because people
just kind of get bored with things that
are extraordinary and new so now they
have to genetically modify and splice
together new dinosaurs and thus it all
turns to Schick's you know what's going
to because we all listen to n Malcolm
from the first movie I do like that that
is a part of this movie they address
that they're like hey that's not a good
idea to do and you did it but ultimately
this new thing called indominus rex gets
out or I call them holy [ __ ] essaouira
so now the crew guys who might as well
be wearing red Star Trek uniforms and
Chris Pratt need to go hunt down holy
[ __ ] ass arse and take them down this
movie does have merit I will save this
merits a strong word I can say this
there is enjoyment to be had in this
movie if you see it as a monster movie
not a Jurassic Park movie but you
shouldn't have to do that I mean it
carries the jurassic title and the logo
it's part of the world so you should be
able to judge this base on the Jurassic
Park role you should be able to compare
this to the first Jurassic Park movie
but it just seems unfair because it
completely pales in comparison
I knew this movie was going to not have
the Jurassic Park magic when the music
was swelling I was getting really
excited you're like oh the park and the
kid swings open the doors like it's
Christmas and the theme done and it's
panning over buildings and buildings as
some should probably be reserved for
really cool [ __ ] like dinosaurs anything
more interesting than the landscape of
buildings it's all I'm saying right
there I was like I don't think they know
how to capture the feels I think this is
gonna be a monster movie everyone in
this movie's a cartoon version of
themselves also Bryce Dallas Howard
she's the really uptight businesswoman
everything needs to be scheduled she
wears high heels to the entire swart to
God I didn't know
until the very end there is a shot at
the end of the movie where you see her
full body shot you're like have you been
doing all that [ __ ] in high heels this
entire time she did it she goes to
recruit Chris Pratt who's pretty much
the velocity like signal velociraptors
like guys eyes on me eyes on me she's
like we need your help and there's this
fly buzzing around her and he's cleaning
a motorcycle he's like it's all about
the relationship and he snatches the fly
he literally grab the fly out of the
area it's like how can I help you he's a
cartoon also Vincent D'Onofrio is like
the militant guy like we need to
weaponize dinosaur Phase II complete
cartoon version of him because this
movie had moments of comedic relief in
it it would've been fine to have comedy
really difference between Jurassic Park
and Jurassic world is the characters
were fallible they were human beings the
comedy relief was said because someone
like Ian Malcolm would say something
that Ian Malcolm said in that moment but
the comedy relief in Jurassic world is
just shoehorned in this movie for the
sake of there being a comedic moment at
the compromise of the moment as a whole
I did like some of the comedy relief in
this movie but I didn't like was when
there was a real moment that completely
failed at being a real moment because
people in the theater were laughing
because it was executed so cheesy and it
became accidental comedy relief you know
that Lion the trailer where Chris
Pratt's like we do this we do it my way
that is like tip of the iceberg [ __ ]
that's not even the worst thing that
I've heard in Jurassic world I don't
even know if that line was in Jurassic
world but it really is not to say there
isn't enjoyment in this movie as a
monster movie the addresses the holy
[ __ ] of Soros is a monster doesn't even
act like a dinosaur because it's like a
Frankenstein so at that point it does
have some fun intense scenes where
psychology we got to get away from holy
[ __ ] of sores oh the pterodactyls are
coming down oh that's crazy - dinosaurs
murder and mayhem what's not the like
really a lot because of the cheesy lines
the predictable [ __ ] everyone in this
movie that was going to die you knew was
going to die it has fun like monster
movie romp moments but it doesn't have
that intention doesn't have the kitchen
scene from the first Jurassic Park movie
out of place comedy relief the fake
tears is one scene with this girl cries
no it was like Charlie Sheen at the end
of Wall Street crying she just it was
bad the movie had conflicting tone
between its comedy relief in its serious
moments the movies a bit messy as a
whole but in the end I will say there is
enjoyment to be had in Jurassic world if
you're drunk yeah now it's a party to it
so the little girl in Jurassic Park was
right when she called them monsters
yeah it's right you remember that [ __ ]
remember when Lex in Jurassic Park
aren't the monsters going to come over
here and Mellon grants like they're not
monsters Lex they're just animals and
you were like all right they're animals
that's right that's really cool I always
saw them as monsters but in reality they
are animals so 20 years later Lex is
validated now they're monsters right
guys so Jurassic world have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more